in 1974 there was a famine in apartment
one area Bangladesh and I went there to
try and do famine relief work they were
Amos seated women and their men
nourished babies all the men have left
and I thought the men abundance children
and women but women don't if we want to
change our society we need to focus our
attention are on our women who are not
going to abandon anybody we found that
when we had it three million war groups
in our micro finance program we had
about 380,000 women who are producing
vegetables for livelihood but we found
that they don't have high-quality
vegetable seeds so we went into seed
multiplication as a business in order to
supply our women with high quality seeds
but then once we have gone into business
not only we supplied to our own clients
but also we applied throughout the
country high quality seeds so
development automatically happened in
the sense that more productive
productive horticulture program was
started throughout Bangladesh so it was
a combination of micro financial
services and then enterprise is training
that we provided them generally so it
was a holistic approach to development
microfinance with plus plus plus means
to providing them support in terms of
inputs and services and training the
other plus is providing them health care
education for their children so at least
you can break this cycle of poverty the
next generation will not be poor
you